hello chess fans and welcome to the
basement of the world-famous st. Louis
chess club for a very special event this
is blitz bounty live here for the first
time on the YouTube channel tonight we
have a very special event T deed by the
one and only mike comer of course who
will be joined with in just a bit
but this is all about Dennis LaRue and a
little bit about redemption my name is
Ben Simon and my co-host tonight is the
world-famous Grandmaster Pepe cuenca
Pepe this is gonna be a really fun event
tonight extremely exciting much it's a
four games match five minutes per player
no delay no increment and the one
reaching two and a half point will win
and if they tell you we'll see an
exciting time again and so it is best of
four which is a departure from the
earlier blitz bounties that might come
or played against the small children
Dennis this was your idea usually in a
blitz bounty when the Challenger just
clinches one victory the match is over
you say we're gonna do a best of four
what's the reasoning behind this give
the viewers something enjoyable to watch
bang and I probably just have poor
decision-making skills in general now I
know that you were talking with Caleb
Denby and Caleb encouraged you to get
your mojo back against Jacob Sanders
here today and I know that's what you
intend to do right but there's a lot on
the line what are you putting up for
your bounty if he beats you today well I
don't make the big bucks like my
cummerbund
so all I'm gonna offer there's still a
lot though is in cash the total that you
would win from one of our Friday action
quads and then just to spice it up a bit
instead of just being thirty six forty
dollars are on the line but the last
four dollars were spent on a Powerball
ticket well that could be worth millions
three hundred and twenty-two million my
goodness now remember this is not
gambling this is simply a bounty
because if Dennis wins well it's just
all about pride he retains his Friday
action
winnings or the equivalent and the
Powerball ticket which could be worth up
to 300 million dollars lot on the line
been a lot on the line
well if Jacob wins he gets the prize
this is gonna be a lot of fun and we
hope you stay with us for about the next
hour as Pepe and I call the action from
inside the studio but we got to get
there first let's get this started
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey Caleb I'm feeling kind of down
lately
what's the real meaning of it all why do
we even play chess when there's just
hours and hours the mental torture
masquerading as a board game I've been
playing chess for years and just hit my
floor in classical I can't even I think
I'm getting worse at blitz chess I just
can't improve at all why should I even
go on that's I know just what you need
oh yeah what's that
challenge a small child to a blitz match
give him the chance to win some money
and then crush his dreams what a
wonderful idea
[Music]
you
[Music]
all right Dennis Larew which hand would
you like to pick would you like the
white hand or the left hand I don't
think the right hand and you get the
white pieces USCF rules are in effect
let's get this thing started
Jacob good luck sir good luck well we
are off to the races
welcome everybody to Game one of four in
this blitz bounty event very suspicious
drawing of the lines there by the one
and only Mike comer but well they're
playing the London system here with
Bishop f4 III Denise is playing pretty
solid opening here with the white pieces
but I saw they started the game without
pressing the clocks in oh but now Queen
c1 okay
upon um b2 was attacked now he had to
defend it Bishop g4 and Magby - the to
protecting the f3 knight c6 Bishop e2
developing the pieces Knight B to d7 and
c3 it looks so serious yeah h3 attacking
this bishop it's got to go back to f5 or
h5 let's see what he does
taking an f3 why would get the bishop
pair so Bishop f5 now g4 comes to my
mind - no instead he goes for castle and
I guess black is gonna do the same you
know I'm surprised because the tradition
of blitz bounty as you saw in that
opening video is getting your mojo back
or teaching a small child a lesson this
is not the case here we have Dennis
LaRue who the fans of our YouTube
channel know for a very long time the 37
year old originally from the LA area or
you know whatever small town in LA and
he came here years ago as a member
and then transitioned into a chess
instructor and a YouTube personality
himself his opponent Jacob Sanders 15
years old from Tulsa Oklahoma is well
Dennis is foil I don't know I think
Jacob may have tricked Dennis into this
match because Jacob's actually higher
rated than Dennis this is not some kind
of phony exhibition I'm gonna blow you
out of the water this is a maybe Dennis
walking into a trap of a man and as you
can see he just blundered an exchange he
touched the rukon a1 and he had to move
it to be one and the bishop um if I just
took that rook so Jacob has a great
advantage already out of the opening
arbiter Mike comer taking a very close
look at this match not letting anything
slip by him now I want to let you know
that these players are encouraged to
trash-talk
to some extent I mean we have a
microphone right next to the board and I
thought this might happen at least the
first game a feeling out process getting
to know the other player because what
worse could happen than talking trash
talking a big game and then dropping the
first the first stands because of it you
know exactly but they seem so quiet yeah
so there are really focus the pride is
on stake a knight eh now I think Dennis
could push the IMP on now going for Eve
for trying to open the position and he
goes for that if or try to create some
sort of attack detective or and Knight
takes e4
so let's see now not if six of course
black would love to exchange a lot of
pieces since his material up so black is
happy exchanging those nights we see
that dennis has 30 more seconds on the
clock
remember no increment no delay yeah I
was really surprised whenever they
mentioned this was no increment no delay
I've never been a fan of that kind of
blitz myself I think it's way too brutal
and fights break out all over the board
all the time because it just gets into a
mad time scramble at the end exactly and
then just stop playing dirty and we
don't want that
stomping toes under the tables yeah
exactly so 95 tuck in the Bishop of my
four now the C three point is very weak
so f5 was a really interesting move a
knight f6 now he's got to protect their
c3 Knight so now he can't avoid the
trade of the Knights if he goes back to
d2 Knight takes c3 just winds up on four
black so probably he's got to take on f6
or maybe something like Queen c2 to
protect this little guy and c3 yes and
he goes for that now this Bishop on h2
could be a dangerous feat piece for
black sari will you give dynasty
advantage at this point no no no here's
a lecture town so black has a better
position but it's not that easy right
because then he has the bishop pair and
also he could start pushing the c4 pawn
gaining more space in the position and
it's not easy so Knight takes e4 Bishop
takes you four and nine f6 intending to
take that pick up a saw Denny shouldn't
allow that and he should go back to d3
this is what he does and now black could
break with the c5 pawn so c6 to c5
opening the c5 for the rook but instead
he goes rook F to d8 and now Knight e5
c5 still it's a good move I guess for
example white could try to go something
like Queen e2 and then sacrifice the
knight on f7 followed by Queen is six
and Bishop g6
that looks
interesting but 97 only two minutes one
is 52 seconds for Jacobs so Queen e2 and
as you can see now you can try to put
the Queen on e4 as well in order to go
Queen 87 so now quickie for it's really
interesting more he is trying to get to
87
is he gonna see it is he gonna see it
let's see let's see
because g6 could run into 90 X g6
beautiful sacrifice bunt dance level and
the quick come to t6 later and there
could be a lot of trouble for Jacob only
one minute and 25 seconds in the clock a
minute down so net f8 covering the 87
squared and for example something like
Knight c4 or even 9g for trying to ruin
black pawn structure could be really
really interesting at this point Knight
g4 and I would say Dennis is the
favorite now because of the time because
the position looks really dangerous for
black even though he's an exchange HUP
96 now 9 t xf64 could be interesting but
black could reply with f5 I'm not so
sure
Knight XF 62
black could play f5 pepe pardon me I'm
gonna see if I can get a closer look at
this board
alright 8 for Dennis is trying to open
the position but now black can reply
with and 5 I'm probably the 8 4 point
could fall in that position so f5 the
thing is you can't go to f4 to protect
the egg for pawn so you're gonna go to
e2 e3 and then Knight takes s4 looks
really interesting less than a minute
for takeoff 1 minute 35 seconds for
Jenny's Queen a free black can't a
connect 4 because of the Queen g3 you
can just retreat your Knight to g6
blacks better still the position looks
pretty pretty complicating only 44
seconds for takeoff this time
he's not taking it it goes for C five
but now h5 could be interesting h5
followed by Bishop eat if I followed by
queen g3 and looks like black could even
be much worse now what happens here
Knight d7 Bishop e5 just threatens Queen
to g3 he calls for King Queen g3
straight away I would like that move
because not the bishop on h2 is doing
basically nothing Queen of fate and now
you could try maybe to go Queen up for
something like that to capture the
eight-six pawn just 27 seconds for
takeoff let's see what happens Queen g5
he's shaking then is she shaking pretty
nervous
Queenie 5 but now C takes d4 looks
interesting because after King h8 ace 98
the nothing happens instead he wants to
run to e8 and I don't know what's going
on here looks pretty complicated only 20
seconds Queen h8 King d7 the King
dancing tango in the center of the world
and now he's gonna take that 286 he's
going to take that pawn r86
rook e8 trying to capture that Queen
it's not gonna happen in Queen g5
probably Brooke g8 so probably blacks
taking the pawn to h5 the pro he's got
only 18 seconds in the clock Danny she's
shaking Queen g5 rook e8 it's gonna go
back 30 seconds he's threatening
checkmate og - lets see it
Danny sees it oh my god Denis does not
handle time pressure well I know this
tee 395 and now
Queenie 5 14 seconds Queen d6 take that
Queen King takes rookie to kidney seven
and now the crazy thing comes Bishop if
I check candy 6 g4 is very interesting
they're like opening this era for the
King 6 second for tennis Bishop takes c3
rookie 1 8 seconds
rookie five kisses 6 take a punt a nice
one second rook 63 he takes out Wow
Jacob Sanders
one-nil I'm gonna start the match in a
big big way and you can tell that Denis
is very upset they're gonna switch sides
switch colors for game number two yeah
what's a break setting game man like ink
tennis blunder an exchange in move
number fifteen or something but then he
was talking a lot and then we managed to
get a great position but then suffered
in the time trouble you know this is not
as big enough this is not a high of us
rating I should say as when comer played
the national master during one of his
blitz bounties i think i think dennis is
getting some water or something no I
think he just needed a break anyway
alright remember guys this let's go a
USCF blitz rated event and it is gonna
be heated here is game to remember if
jacob wins this he will start the match
to zero which means that to win to
retain his money to retain his powerball
dennis will have to win games three and
four and the armageddon which would be
forced yes Queens gambit declined where
White has just played Bishop e2 in order
to go short Castle here then probably
the rook is gonna come to c1 and then
it's go c5 c takes e5 probably now
Knight takes d5 is the best move and
this is what Dennis does we should take
C 7 8 XE 7 this is a pretty solid
position for black now and sure Castle
the thing is if black takes on d4
probably you're gonna take with the
night because you take with a pawn this
looks like it could isolate in bone
structure position for white so that's
why he took with the knife and not a 6
and at some point why would probably try
to use the C and D files for drugs
the problem for rack in this position is
that c8 Bishop as you can see and for
example the white bishop could land on
f3 to put some pressure on b7 so what do
you think Ben who's gonna win this game
I like white right now I like Jacob I
like his position yeah it feels more
comfortable to me
yeah the bishop beat on f3 it's doing a
fantastic job and it's never easy to
play b6 in these positions because c6
could be weak and he goes Queen e2 now
intelligible rook F to d1 and rook a to
c1 and black screen hasn't got too many
squares mostly if you go b6 after rook F
t1 the Queen it's not so well placed
now maybe b6 is the best squared you got
to c7 then that could run into some
night to b5 attacking the Queen going to
be six better squared but also you could
try 94 at some point or even just taking
on c6 and white pawn structure is a
little bit better let's say 96 PTX e6
and then b3 in order to go through kc
one night for a night c5 so three
minutes 54 Jacob 3 for 59 for Dennis and
for those of you just joining us and Ben
Simon here joined along with Grandmaster
Pepe cuenca this is live
yes for real you aren't dreaming this is
blitz bounty live for the first time
ever
Dennis LaRue with his $36 and Powerball
ticket on the line is taking on his foil
Jacob Sanders now if you're wondering
the history between these two it's a
little complicated they I thought it was
a teacher-student relationship because
Dennis is a chess instructor however
actually they met in a tournament
they've played for rated games but they
both think these are their first blitz
games ever and their blitz rate at USC F
so they're tied so far lifetime score
very dubious decision for Dennis to put
this much on the line with not a lot to
gain seemingly other than prides we'll
see how it turns out yeah I just said
there are $40 on stake but there's much
more no no 36 36 last four and lottery
right yes Powerball so you could walk
away with 300 morning it out that's what
I mean yeah I would love to see Danny's
face if this happens here he just loses
like three million dollars
whatever yeah you know Dennis would say
he wouldn't be upset but him I think he
would never sleep again but okay Black
has take this Bishop on f3 so I think I
started to like a little bit more blacks
position the only problem is this which
one c8 he should really do something
about it for example Bishop d7 looks
pretty natural
he goes through da Luke d1 and for
example now taking on d4 and then Bishop
d7 but it's urgent
you've got to do something about this
guy in CA they could beat some Queen g3
also talking through can be 8 so Bishop
d7 finally he brings out this guy from
CA
and the pitcher plants on c6 I would
even prefer blacks position this Bishop
would be doing a fantastic job in this
era and 94 let's see what happens now I
guess Knight takes e4 it's possible and
after Queen takes Bishop c6 and Black
has nothing to worry about position is
around equal but you know everything can
happen this is a blitz game not
increment normally if this would be a
calcium versus Nakamura again I would
say sub tetra but this isn't that card
also yeah this is Danny's versus Jacob
yeah still a lot pieces in the board so
everything can happen I guess now you
gotta take on d8 everything and then
Queen D for something like that and then
we reach this again night versus Bishop
where you should go f3 f4 in order to do
something against this is exhibition
let's see only 2 minutes
Jacobs is thinking too much that could
be problematic in the final phase of the
game so you can remove the Queen Marie
let's say maybe also Queen d3 works
maybe Queen d3 works as well but I will
see any difference oh do something
1:30 he takes everything rook takes yet
now you gonna take probably Queen D for
this is the line that we were saying
before
don't blunder checkmate
don't play Queen h4 don't do that Queen
d4 right protecting the D 1 square and
Queen takes I see Dennis with a lot of
confidence I don't know if that looks
like happiness he's shaking his head
here now at the end you should bring the
key into the center it's a really
important piece don't do that in the
middle game of course because there are
a lot of heavy pieces but in the end
game the key is really important piece
so a6 covering the be 5 squared and now
then it's wants to bring the King to d6
so I would say black is a little bit
better because you have got the bishops
sorry the bishop and there are pawns in
both flanks so if I just drop the piece
okay yeah he recovered it dirty tricks
from tourneys Knight b3 intended to jump
to c5 soaked in d6 is the most natural
move here Bishop b5 so he checks in case
that is checkmate but it's not big time
deficit here for Jacob Sanders is white
only 45 seconds left
and now Keaney for active King attacking
the e5 pawn I would play key in d6
but he goes for f6 now maybe you could
try to go to F fight and then g6 black
is threatened to play Bishop c6 and take
the g2 point that's why white played f3
now there's no bishop c6 two minutes for
then it's just play killed a 6-10 Bishop
d6 sorry Bishop c6 then try to play f5
and black black could be a bit better
king d6
covering c5 and look at that Nidal
Beatrice doing basically nothing so
Bishop c6 followed by King d5 could be
an interesting variation for black
centralizing the king he shoved e7 not
Knight c4
g4 Wow the thing is you can't move now
the knight from d2 because if you do
that there is Bishop c6 and the poetry
is hanging
so he goes g6 he wants to play f5 and
kick this came from there
very interesting 20 seconds you gotta
grow something King d3 is not going to
be enough with 18 seconds I would say
yes I'm telling you this is why I do not
like this no delay no anchor in Jacob is
lost there's nothing you can do the game
is over yeah exactly with 13 seconds
it's just impossible to play yet five
maybe we'll see a miracle here taxi for
takes takes the game is draw probably
but there's just no pre moves over the
board this is gonna be lost on the clock
unfortunately yeah b3 b4 check could be
play six seconds yeah Dani is going to
win this game three seconds F takes F
takes king e - yeah he won I'm tying one
one Ben
alright well hey we're going the
distance well Dennis is being so humble
you know these are some of the best USC
FC level players I've ever seen in my
life they really shouldn't sell
themselves short and this match I'm sure
I think I can't see the numbers right
now but I'm sure just thousands of
people are watching us right now on
YouTube and as you can see Jacob is
sponsored by adidas you know so well
thank you Mike comer
Mike doing a fantastic job they're not
allowing any dirty tricks we're off Game
three the Blitz bounty remember Dennis
LaRue has nothing to gain but pride but
he has everything to lose
Jacob Sanders the young up-and-comer 15
years old going after that $36 the
price for an average Friday action quads
here at the st. Louis chess club and the
very very awesome Powerball ticket I
mean awesome because of the potential
that it carries you could win millions
of dollars or nothing but you know it's
gonna be a big prize for him if he's
able to win yeah exactly looks like
Danny has prepared deeply the London
system it didn't look like that like in
the previous game when he blundered the
exchange in 15 moves but still he's
trying he's going to play h3 to put this
Bishop on h2 black he's playing some
sort of King's Indian now he brought he
wants to break on e5 let's say after
Knight d7 but then this Bishop on f5
could be in danger
after some g4 move do you know that
dance does favor the London system look
how happy he is right now
the London system for Dennis works for
him but also something you need to know
about Dennis is I understand he has a
top-secret training technique well and
he will not tell us what it is we've
really been digging for it but this is
really says I'm using it to prepare for
this match against Jacob and it's gonna
lead me to victory
I'm he says he invented it if you can do
that did he hire a second for this
tournament no I don't think he has a
second for this tournament buddy I think
he is someone is hiring him for an
upcoming ok match as a second yeah ok
maybe we'll be seeing that training
technique for the UH for the player down
the line we saw Jacob retreating his
Bishop to c8 because he wanted to go if
I went with the bishop on f5 could be in
trouble right after these g4 moves so
that's why he went back to see a not a
very natural move but he managed to
break a me fight now and then his his
thinking if taking on e5 of maybe going
back to h2 but now he blundered the pawn
on e4 as you can see he takes e4 and
Dennis looks really upset now after
ctext e4 Knight takes e4 and Jacob
sapone up in this position just really
early on you know now you're gonna
suffer you're gonna suffer for seven
more minutes potentially but there is
it's a tough guy yeah he fights a lot as
we saw in there in the
first game even though he ended up
losing he put a lot of resistance
material done so Queen c2 and now after
Knight xe2 he would tag - he would have
to take on on D - with the Queen
since the bishop on e2 is hanging so
also for example 93 could be a really
interesting move here right after Bishop
takes c3 rook takes e to winning the
bishop pair but he went for the most
natural continuation Knight XE - Quinta
XE - I guess now you got to develop the
Bishop from c8 for example something
like 9 f6 covering the e4 and e5 square
in order to develop the CI be sure for
example Knight f6 followed by Bishop e6
of Bishop f5 looks completely natural to
me we want to thank you all for joining
us on YouTube and twitch it's a
simulcast Bensimon here with the one and
only grandmaster pepe cuenca in english
if you can believe it for this blitz
bounty live it's Dennis LaRue versus
Jacob Sanders best of 4 games 5 the
gaming 5 no delay no increment the score
is 1 to 1 this is game number three and
I would like this d5 move because now
the h2 Bishop is back to life because
now you can see there's a really
beautiful diagonal for this Bishop the
pawn on d6 and C separate they were
doing a fantastic job but okay still
black is much better of course because
you're a pawn app a healthy pawn up
Knight f6 now you want to jump to the e4
square and finally after developing the
c8 Bishop black could be in a very good
shape so what is he what is Dan is doing
now rook takes the 8 followed by rookie
1 he wants some control of the e-file 98
this night on d6 also perfectly placed
not only trying to go to e4 but also c4
it could be its own at some point also
even f5 putting more pressure on the d4
pawn so this time no time trouble for
Jacob is playing faster that's really
important now Bishop d6 followed by rook
e8
could be really really interesting for
white here in this position background
problems Bishop d6 followed by rook e8
here and go
for that queen f4 enough tonight a5 or
94 I think black is in good shape but
Bishop d6 was a really interesting move
maybe Dennis didn't see it
and Dennis could put some pressure on
this
efore night by playing Bishop d3 the
bishop on f1 is doing nothing come on
Dennis bring this bishop back to life is
there a song that says something like
this bring me back to life or something
do you think about voodoo or something I
don't know I don't know some rock
trooper yeah yeah from Finland I guess
so
Queen f6 f7 was attacked and now what
are we gonna do here for example white
could take or white could even play f3
why could take another six and then play
f3 followed by Knight g4 and then again
you could bring the rook to e8 one
minute 40 seconds for Dennis Bishop d3
pressure on the e4 Knight let's say
quinna for Bishop f4 and for example you
could play Knight f6 Jacob is not
developing the c8 Bishop which I don't
like you managed to do that you're much
better but you don't do that they could
be background problems Mike is too
serious they're controlling everything
you see well you know you've gotta have
a good arbiter and an international he's
an international I guess the top of the
food chain for a match like this with no
delay or no increment I mean we might
see a fistfight over the board
gotta get security in here exactly
that's why in tournaments we play with
increment but here you're like tough
fights I play out in the streets yeah
in the who's right outside the Chess
Club yes what they play you try to play
increment here people are like what what
are you talking about I don't want to
play increment 5 minutes take it or
leave it
again Jacob in tiny trouble not if 6
pretty solid move controlling me 8 now
finally I hope he goes for Bishop e6 at
3 controlling me 497 again I don't like
these kind of moves there's no control
on EA for example Knight f3 and then I
know there's no Natick free there's a
pond on f3 already then it's played f3
so the thing is now you can't retreat to
d4 because d4 is hanging so Jacob is
going to exchange everything and finally
bring the bishop out I hope so Bishop e6
Denis looks distressed right now Denis
just look straight up distressed King F
to bringing the King to the center and
one minute per for each player here
let's say B shall be 5 and then King g7
followed by Keane f6 rook e8 Bishop d7
you trade a pair of rooks Oh F 6 fish of
h2 now the bishop on his sake is hanging
in f7 black who try to play f5 but then
Bishop e5 again and nothing happens with
the d4 pawn Bishop d6 by Denis and Jacob
is thinking too much he should hurry up
f5 Bishop e5 by Denis probably come on
Dennis Bishop e5 that's right now be
careful Jake off because white is
threatened to take on g7 that's why he
played rookie a bishop takes King takes
and even though blacks upon up there are
some witnesses on the dark squares as
you can see and 40 seconds for Dennis
rookie 5 we should be 7 you can take
everything and then play f4 and f5 and
it would be extremely half of why to
make any progress in this position so
let's see what then he starts f4
controlling e5 b5 I don't like that move
at all because now black could actually
break with c5 after sunk in d6 which it
takes me five two versus one on the
queenside so now blacks much better
Bishop e6 followed by Bishop d7 tracked
into a four point you gotta defend that
pawn on e4 he just blunders to pawn 20
seconds for Dennis and now we should be
to be faced going to run now B 5 B 4 B 3
T 4 trying to create some contemplate
but Jacob is not denying anything
takes on a5 Bishop takes me 5 Bishop
takes me 5 8 5 could be the move 14
seconds 5 seconds Bishop d7 now you go
ahead 43 go go grand and run Bishop c4
just wings black is winning and then
it's lost this game to the wood for
Jacob Sanders now remember the only way
next game decides the mansion that's
exactly right thank you Mike comer to
retain his plunder Dennis LaRue must win
this game and force a 5 minute versus 4
minute blitz Armageddon and hey there's
no increment or delaying that either so
this is gonna be very exciting we are
here guys
we're it game number 4 this is it this
is what it's all about can Jacob put
Dennis away okay good luck for those who
don't know and I'm a Ganim game means
that white is first to win yes Black has
drawn if the game goes to a draw then
black gets the nod as if black one in
the first place the offset there is that
white has five minutes and black has
four minutes so mathematicians I guess
would say equals I have a winner we see
the same opening again this Queens
gambit Bishop d3 in seven Bishop takes
b7 the previous game went pretty well
for
Jenny's so now Bishop g3 very
interesting move this diagonal is is
pretty interesting for the whites Bishop
a matter of six maybe intended to go
Knight h5 at some point trying to grab
the bishop pair for example Knight X III
followed by Knight h5 could be
interesting since after Bishop e5 black
to just go something like f6c text e4
and now the point is if you take with
the night then Knight takes c3 and
blacks better because of the pawn
structure so that's why he took first on
d5 Knight takes d4 and now position
looks again balanced still I prefer
white for example Bishop f3 and look at
those two bishops two in a fantastic job
from this to they are honest Bishop d7
and the point is you can't go to c6
because Knight takes c6 white will grab
the bishop pair and a better structure
also White has the option of going Eve
were in these positions kicking this
night from d5 and black hasn't the
option of going e five rooks e8 4
minutes per player and not f6 Bishop f3
now then it has to do something about
the b7 point again Queen b6 looks like
the most natural move protecting b7
connecting the rooks
preparing the FA troop to join the party
there is a salsa party on the D file
Bishop c6 I don't like that move okay
white can take with the knight on c6
because because of queen taxi to but
after Bishop c6
I guess white is much better because
you're forcing black to take with upon
or wait wait maybe after Bishop c6 white
black who tagged with the rook and you
can't still take the rook on c6 because
of Queen takes t2 right so Bishop c6
after all maybe a good move by Denis LA
who is
how you pronounce the surname it's a
pretty tough surname for Spanish guy
well Pepe I always thought that it was
LaRue no roots an awfully friendship you
okay yeah I should be able to pronounce
in a better way right but you know
that's me now I always ask how do you
actually pronounce your name I asked it
almost everybody back because you know
you have like the American Way and then
you have like the real way okay if I can
say it the real way I want to say that
name the real way okay see so what's
your name my big Winker
lovely well I gotta write about that
guys this is it this is the final game
Jacob with with just a draw can put
Dennis little rule away in this blitz
game 94 Wow
94 some tactics tactics going on so
Knight takes c6 I guess Knight takes c6
what happens with this move Knight takes
c6 Knight XD 290x d8 and not a3 check
and nothing happens for black here so
you guys can follow knight c6 Knight XE
to next da matta 3d takes every and rook
takes d8 and nothing happens so I guess
if white takes on e4 then blacks better
because dennis has to Bishop her as you
can see this Bishop is doing a fantastic
job on e4 after f3 I guess you would
have to change the Yahoo now and go to
87 since on c6 can be captured by the d4
Knight rook a to C 1 and now the first
move that comes to my mind is Queen b6
again connecting the rooks then is again
in good shape
does God 1 minute up Bishop f6 okay
activating this Bishop to rook c8 Quincy
8 and maybe something like Queen B 4
could be interesting so looking with
x-rays to this in for Bishop right Queen
before now there could be some night xe8
at this point because the bishop on e4
is unprotected
there that's a shame in his head - he's
shaking his head Nakamura style
so take some c1 and I guess now beeshit
xt4 would be interesting but he goes we
should be seven he wants more he was he
needs more turn natural of course
Misha takes him for and then opposite
color bishops that's good for Jacob so
that's why he has to keep some pieces in
the bird to trick Jacob and he's doing
pretty well because now Jacob has only
one and a half minute versus almost
three minutes for Dennis
so Jacob where are you going with your
queen maybe to a for maybe 2 e 1 to D to
C 3 lot of options going on sorry a lot
of action options available Queen C 4
and I guess he wants to go to C 7 now
Bishop d4 sorry bishop d5 Queen c7 you
can take on c7
or I guess you shouldn't take on g7
because the rook would be extremely
active on the seventh rank he's gonna
take that but I guess white is a little
bit better now Bishop f6 for example I
mean if I could play some efore that's
not possible because the knight on d4 is
hanging so maybe Bishop d6 but then
group da nothing happens for black rook
da he wants to go Bishop e7 and wind the
bishop pair back so Bishop e7 Black's
first to take him east 7 rook takes e7
and I guess white is a little bit better
because of the rook on the seventh Frank
I would have preferred to go rook e8 to
stop Bishop e7 and now Bishop e7 I guess
it's a good movement 40 seconds for
Jacob and we might be seeing the 4th
consecutive game where black wins this
is a bit all-black this entire match
exactly
okay 635 seconds for jacob bibby six no
threats because the rookin v8 is
protected so there's no Ruger 7 or
something like that would be just a
blunder it's not easy to make a move
with the black pieces maybe II five at
some point he five would be really
interesting since white could have a lot
of background problems he's got to go to
DA and be careful Dennis because there
could be a triple repetition f3 Jacob is
going for the win now II five again
looks to me pretty reasonable if I
followed by E for maybe one and a half
mean up for Dennis he's doing what he
hasn't got to do play slowly I think he
just plays fast he will just win this
game but is there anything to worry
about now for Dennis anymore
I guess he's worried about some efore
move because the bishop Hansen got too
many squares you can't go to c4 because
the b7 pawn is hanging you can't go to
c6 because the knight would just
captured that bishop so he decided to
take on d4 the safest option this is
probably a draw but 26 seconds for Jacob
bishops a six it's going to go if for a
Keaney free centralizing the King Bishop
b6 then is good you cannot move fast
King f8 e for rookie stop play rock e7
because there is fish up see if I okay
here the blow the roof f7 check now
black has to take that group really fast
Bishop da once upon a pair only 19
seconds in the clock b5 thank four
seconds Bishop d7 b for 30 seconds 410
is 85 all the points in the light square
so white can take them pitch weights to
King d7 King III King c6 Weston is going
he can go anywhere but up King Bishop e5
it was going fine takes takes another
it's going to a four but then still it
can never take that point on a three
maybe just keen be free or something
like that
Jacob is completely winning in this
position takes only six four points
Michels to but only five seconds Bishop
e7 cakes and d6 then he stole he got
crazy he took the pawn on e4 e5 three
seconds three seconds only for Jacob
King D 3 e 7 we gotta move fast and he's
two seconds take six
hey Jacob takes 1 would be a drawing he
would be winning but now he lost some
time incredible only one more move to
make a draw and win the match okay
alright so who's taking wipeout well
we're about to find out
Mike comers going to make a draw they're
going to draw a lot we will do the
drawing of the lots again so the way the
arm again works white gets five minutes
and must win the game to win the match
black will receive four minutes and all
he needs to do to clinch the match is
either draw or win this is not USCF
rated and if you illegally do the poem
promotion you lose okay enjoying it
blogs
that's you had your choice you have the
would you like what's in my right hand
or I'm gonna go with the right hand
right hand white pieces all right let's
do this right okay if you got your
choice would you take the draw odds in
black or will you take it black
good luck good luck good luck
all right last game guys before I'm not
the London system so but Jacob is
changing so now he's playing faster but
then they got only four minutes as you
can see Jacob only four minutes takes on
g6 H takes c6 Knight B to D to Knight B
to d7 C 3 is 6 so Queen e2 and now
probably Bishop e7 in order to go short
castling here in this position Knight b6
I don't like that move the knight is
going basically nowhere from there so
you can't jump to c4 you're not
reinforcing the c5 break so it's not a
move that I like to do here but ok it
seemed like then is it's not sure about
what to do a3 Bishop d6 that was his
idea
developing the base to d6 in order to
fight for the central square e 5 now
then is place 95 in order to avoid the
exchange of the dark square bishop let's
see if Dennis King can do something here
with why I know it's been all black all
the entire match 0 1 all the way through
but Dennis has a very special friend
watching this event
Caleb Denby one of the personalities of
the st. Louis chess club YouTube channel
a close friend of Dennis LaRue and
confidant
Caleb Denby is playing in the match
a couple of months April 12th to be
specific we're calling it all in and on
you're hearing it here first
Dennis LaRue is going to be seconding
Caleb Denby in a match against Jonathan
shruts now I I know that this is not
going to be very impressive to Caleb if
Dennis cannot pull through this victory
I don't think it's going to hurt their
relationship long term but it's also an
interesting story to be looking at this
Caleb how you doing if you're watching
and thanks for watching us here on
YouTube and on twitch Ben Simon here
with Grandmaster Pepe cuenca yeah I got
to say that I have played against both
Kaleb and Jonathan they're really strong
they they said that there are two
thousand rated or something but I found
them pretty stronger yeah Jonathan made
his name with the famous chess opening
is explained YouTube seriously with
those hours and hours just give these
great lectures and look at that night on
e4 for example after something like beef
or not now because he fries hanging but
there could be applied like Queen D free
before and then try to trap that night
by playing at three at some point
okay now the B Phi square is unprotected
but he calls Queen B five I would have
preferred to go Knight b5 you know in
order to go f3 and Knight to d6 check
actually after Knight d5 followed by f3
I think white would be much better now I
like blacks position I guess Queen Texas
seven ollie move because you can retreat
your night the queen is hanging Queen
Texas having King take c7 and then you
could have moved your night probably
haven't go King in c6 to reinforce the
center with my king and then bring the
rooks to an ascent to the center Knight
f3 by tennis he's forced to win this
game remember that guy's f6 f6 probably
he wants to go some g5
but now c4 could be very very strong in
this position I guess blacks only move
would be king c6
otherwise the pawn on d5 would be just
hanging so I can say six only move
see txt he takes the and now probably
group c1 threatening some sort of a lot
of ideas for example 94 check could be
an idea and this position also look as
2d one and there's a lot of pressure on
those central pawns also before could be
an idea in these positions to gain the
d4 squared well and now also look at
this the white one minute advantage has
completely evaporated which is great
news for black given the results in the
job just because after King d7 two
pieces are attacked right the bishop on
f4 and the knight on d4 I think 94 is a
bad move King d7 and after 86 just King
EA because King being sick I think it
still wins maybe he could try to go
tonight I fight now 95 only move that's
why but then he can take that night and
Jacob is with him in this position and
when Dennis knows it oh he can kiss that
$36 and Powerball ticket goodbye you
never know in chess but he's winning
terrible blunder 94 check I know f3
maybe well this knife is almost front
for example rook FD 1 could be a move
trying to trap this knife but then he's
got to jump to d2 and then probably this
night is going to c4 and nothing happens
for black here look at the one night c4
for example and then the night guy goes
to a 5 on c6 putting a lot of pressure
on the d4 point B 3 is going to be
played 95 or 93 now rook e1
could be the most rock c8 black is much
much better now he also got the C file
this rook is coming to see - at some
point and now after 95 lot of troubles
for the default
let's say only move rook t1 now to
protect the d4 but then they saw a huge
boom night xe4 if route d1 now you can
play Knight takes e4 because the rukon
c8 is hanging but Bishop e3 it would be
a really strong move first in Group D 1
and then boom Knight takes d4 and at the
root XT for Bishop c5 would be winning
he didn't see that Bishop f6 probably
Denis is trying to bring their king he
can never go to e 2 because this Knight
takes d4 check so don't go to it - Denis
maybe to g3 and then g4 try to collect
some pawns
teammate 6 was not a very good move and
for trying to create a passport one
minute per player takes takes come on
Dennis what are you waiting why you
don't take the pawn take T 4 brilliant
he wants to go to add three with the kid
now he can't take the pawn on d4 because
Lukas he had this protective and now
it's going to run with h-bomb he got a
run to the h1 h v g5 but now now black
can't stop pretty easily at that point
with 96 covering g7 King D 76 and White
has to resign a 3 B 5
kingi - I don't think he's gonna resign
Pepe I don't think it's gonna resign you
got to fight out in the end
Tina 5 is gonna take that cheap one and
he's smelling the the 40 bucks he can't
marry 636 + 3 million dollars a 94
illegal move they didn't see the illegal
both 92
sorry kini 2 takes the knight is going
back to C - I'm actually once you take
the pawn on b4 what can we say because
you can only get a prop
yeah it sounds like Dennis is doing all
about resigning with those sounds he's
making now knight c6 Knight x before
there it is Oh No
and now he was residing making me work
for it I'm gonna make you work for it
okay much well that was something else
guys lost the game well we're gonna talk
about the players we're gonna take a
short break and when we come back we're
gonna talk to the players about their
experience and with our let's bounty
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the st. Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions the Chess Club and
scholastic Center of st. Louis is
recognized as the top chess facility in
the world and plays host to all major
tournaments including the u.s. Chess
Championships and a Sinquefield Cup one
of the strongest chess tournaments
globally tournaments are broadcast
online - more than 150 countries led by
an expert commentary team of
grandmasters the Chess Club is an
educational organization committed to
promoting the game of chess with a
specific focus on bringing the benefits
of chess to children throughout the st.
Louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the Chess Club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week directly across the
street from the Chess Club is the world
chess Hall of Fame this one-of-a-kind
cultural institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the US and world chess halls
of faith cutting edge exhibitions
feature rare historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions and monthly music in the
galleries the World Chess Hall of Fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premier gift shop highlight the culture
history and creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched to
learn more about the st. Louis chess
campus visit STL chess campus org
ally of blitz bounty live for the very
first time here on the st. Louis Chess
Club YouTube channel man we've had a
real blast tonight Bensimon along with
grandmaster pepe cuenca we just really
had a good time thank you to Mike comer
the one person who didn't have a good
time still see that his his desk we'll
have to get a word with him actually
Dennis come on up here I'm here with the
winner but we got to get the the person
who has the bounty here we got to grab
the bounty here Dennis
this has got got to be the hand off it's
tradition now you know a sportsmanship
and all that so Dennis what do you have
to say for this for this match to your
opponent Jacob well-played Jacob come on
in so we can see this all right let's
make it official
spectacular Jacob how does it feel to
come in and beat the man in his own
house it feels pretty good I mean I I
did a lot of preparation for this I
played non-stop blitz for I'd say about
two to three weeks ever since hearing
about this and I would like to thank my
good friend Erik to chenko for preparing
me for this he's a tough guy played
Erica Janko many times so you got the
Powerball which you can't actually
redeem since you're 15 but I'm sure your
parents can cut you a deal what are you
going to do with the $36 uh food we play
to eat here at the Chess Club well this
has been just a really great night
Jacob congratulations once more anything
else you want to say I'd like to say
that I had a really good time and I
loved the series
hey before we sign off though we have
some business to tend to
Dennis come on in because we have some
big events coming up we were talking in
the room Dani can you see both of us
right now they got to see both of us
okay so here's what here's what we have
coming up so this Saturday we have a
tournament called the spring chess
classic and we're gonna be looking at
some really fine 2500 level 2600 level
players and we're gonna have live
commentary for 9 days straight here on
the Chess Club
YouTube channel you should definitely
check it out at us chest champs calm but
a little bit further down the line we
have something we're doing for the very
first time
and we're gonna call it all in and you
are a part of it you are a little bit I
worked with Caleb Denby yes we were
talking about Caleb Denby and I'm sure
he was watching this match here tonight
Caleb Denby will be taking on Jonathan's
rants and a battle of two of the most
prominent YouTube channel personalities
in the seven-year history of this great
media outlet and we don't know if
Jonathan has an extra or a second rather
but we know that Caleb does and we know
that you have a technique and I know
I've been trying to get it out of you
and you haven't been telling me anything
you'll have to wait you're not gonna
tell me anything about the training
technique no we'll have to wait and see
don't worry we'll get it out of him that
is gonna be on April 12th so a little
bit of ways away I know that our friend
Danny Machuca is working on some videos
to hype this event up because it's
really gonna be an event like you've
never seen before the strongest
expert-level matchup in the st. louis
chess club streaming history so Dennis
you're a great sportsman thank you for
joining us Mike comer thank you very
much for TD and I know with gaming five
with no delay no increment it can get
kind of messy sometimes so that's all
for this time pepé you want to come in
here and sign out with me we're gonna
draw this out as long as possible to
make everyone stay up late what do you
think of today's match was very exciting
yeah it was very exciting with a lot of
time so I really had a great time with
you guys well it's been a great time
thanks for joining us and staying up
late wherever you are and until next
time this is Grandmaster Pepe cuenca and
Ben Simon saying so long from the
show-me-state